hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master riccardi here let's see
what we get I've got a 50-percent score
against him King top three wins three
losses yeah if I've is a questionable
line but so one of those lines where you
should know how to do talk to play it
and I don't I looked at this for black
like a million years ago I don't know if
it was this my head or something else
it's usually a bad version of the night
off but I don't know what this is the
right way to do it this looks okay right
that cannot be possibly bad for white
keep it simple here I does he get in d5
no c4 it's a good move
let's check this if I go I need to
prevent md5 he has rook to t4 which is a
problem Queen f3 I wonder if he has some
kind of tactic available them don't I
don't see one thumb d5 I can take look
at for queen bee three
what why tries to do is to claim that
his bishop is better on your phone in
the bishop on your six but this demands
precision so yeah would like to place
you three year but probably not clear
that I needed actually under bishop only
four covers situ it's not totally
necessary move so again he has no d5 so
I can maybe improve my king safety
background issues
yeah do I want to trade actually not
it's not so easy to avoid i roped you
what is a bit passer so let's trade a
look here and then you'll see if i can
trade even more Wow why didn't you do
that with the queen is also possible I
don't know outlook good if he goes for
the ending and also not unhappy here so
what shakes me I don't know rupee seven
looks better maybe you can take that
okay let's let's let's do this and now
look b7 until potentially be 55 d 4935
could could be an issue here
hmm let's trade the trades a bit too
much I don't want to do that look on the
seventh water bad idea actually what did
it that it was a bad move should I play
look a five immediately or something
along these lines now married which is
technical flame not a good technical
flame yeah it's a yes d5 now doesn't
play that hmm ok ok that this move might
be good as well but but I have this one
actually
I'm just not moving here this is a bad
problem I shouldn't make moves time
warning
yeah pretty bad what I did here with
this position technically speaking and
now by now the time is getting a serious
problem this is why I'm going through
this it's just simpler to play my place
free air okay didn't do it
yeah I cannot I cannot move I cannot
move from my pawns however there was no
biggie need to give them this one check
this chick was also kind of stupid right
okay it's so pretty impossible to use it
however I mean being in a situation
where i need to think about the draw is
kind of bad draw a third
so I'm going to draw i think without the
the pawns draw a third drum authorized
yeah well i have to win this game of
course but it didn't didn't manage that
the technical play I think I made a
couple of bad decisions here I mean of
course you can argue about taking with
the roof because the middle game is also
fantastic but I don't think it's that
terrible and so from from here I'm very
unhappy with what I did this is already
a point this move because king of Ages I
mean yeah he will play this anyway so I
have to improve some somewhere here yeah
the computer wants to play b3 youjizz
possible but nothing that makes me super
happy maybe it's still correct maybe
it's still correct yeah I get Bishop to
g5 and the a porn is running that's
that's probably the right way to do it
but you know that I think of it I mean
why didn't I just play this it's an
absolutely terrible position for like I
mean I can play here Bishop up to be
seven I create a look up to be seven I'm
sorry I keep forgetting to switch the
zone and this is a disaster
ya mean actually I totally did not
understand this I mean he has to play
here to play for a draw I mean black is
always worse in this position and stuff
like a four is just uncalled for and not
winning is pretty awful but the hip from
here Wendy five was also stronger quite
clearly as I mentioned does this gives
him an immediate draw here I mean it is
probably by far already too active and
okay this is not the way to play for win
but I needed to be able to play quick
move chap energy for and was
straightening it to complete role this
is drawn without their the pause i think
i'm just having a fortress and sarah
fortress see i can go back and forth him
and even without a and P porn yeah it
should be due in a way thanks for
watching